why do you do what you do what creates a
sense of purpose for you is it working
volunteering being with your family
these are not trivial questions research
shows that having a strong sense of
purpose creates more meaning in life
improves health and leads to greater
satisfaction from work purpose means
intention having a stable far-reaching
goal when we're pursuing our purpose we
feel our lives are more meaningful now
meaning is an abstract concept but
recently behavioral scientists have made
progress toward understanding it better
and even measuring it
I recently conducted a study with my
colleagues roy baumeister kathleen baz
and emily garb in ski where we asked
adults to rate on a seven-point scale
whether their lives were meaningful we
also asked about their beliefs behaviors
and choices those who deem their lives
most meaningful were those that gave the
most to others these same people also
felt the most strongly connected to the
past and future not just the here and
now they had a strong sense of where
they came from and an equally strong
sense of where they're going a purpose
so the feeling of meaning increases when
we feel connected to others and
something bigger than ourselves when we
feel we're part of a story that started
in the past and concludes well into the
future
what's more meaning is not something you
just have or don't have it's more about
your mindset when individuals adopt a
meaning mindset they behave in very
different ways
in one study two researchers Veronica
Hooda and Richard Ryan had half of their
subjects adopt a meaning mindset by
asking them to do one thing each day to
create meaning these activities like
strengthening a social connection
pursuing excellence or helping others
often required effort yet three months
later these subjects reported less
negative moods and more positive
feelings about their social connections
suggesting that meaning can decrease
stress
and boost well-being in the long run as
people find more meaning in their lives
they also tend to get healthier
psychologist Carol riff and her
colleagues demonstrated this in a study
that trapped thousands of people over
time the people living more meaningful
lives by their own account we're
healthier than those who while happy did
not have the same sense of meaning the
high meaning people had higher levels of
good cholesterol healthier weight they
even slept better they have lower levels
of cortisol the stress hormone in their
saliva and where lower risk for
cardiovascular disease and Alzheimer's
disease they also live longer to figure
out why researchers had subjects report
their levels of meaning and then put the
subjects into an fMRI machine then they
show them images of negative things like
crying babies or car accidents the
participants then rated whether the
images were neutral or unpleasant the
brain scans showed that the high meaning
people had less activity in the amygdala
the part of the brain that processes
fear they also reacted more slowly to
the negative images taking longer to
decide whether the pictures were
unpleasant in other words people with
high meaning in life are better able
with the help of their prefrontal cortex
to control their negative emotions
they're better able at putting things in
perspective these findings have
implications for work to people who feel
their work lacks meaning are more likely
to slack off or feel dissatisfied with
their employers the problem is most
people feel this way about their work at
least that was the case in one
large-scale study which tracked over
12,000 employees across a broad range of
categories and showed 50% lacked a sense
and meaning at work the employees who
did derive meaning from their work were
more than three times as likely to stay
with their companies they also reported
1.7 times higher job satisfaction and
were 1.4 times more engaged at work
which brings us back to the original
question why do you do what you do if
you work only for the money chances are
you're less effective than you can be
but if your answer entails meaning your
work helps you become part of a bigger
story and feel connected to others then
it will help you be stronger healthier
and more resilient